tomorrow's the first time kids I
recruited and closed later sports if you
get trapped in the NFL school
you caught athletes
I'm gonna wear this for like a month and
people could be like do you know where
he picked that up
[Music]
hey guys super weird day today not a lot
of content because I was in an off site
for like five or six hours super
interesting hanging out with a bunch of
very very smart people you know work
some of the things that suck about this
blog is I'm not able to give you
everything but um
hope you guys are super well I'm really
[ __ ] no game right now I'm like in it
obviously does can tell watch by the
vlog so the first time it's been like a
month straight tie show Tyler's had that
probably the best that's probably it's
probably the [ __ ] highlight of the
episode that is an under priced
arbitrage when I think when clients come
to me and say Gary great news we've now
spent sixty percent of our money on
digital I usually get scared because I
do believe that most of the creative
programmatic banner and pre-roll stuff
that my clients are buying is worse than
television commercials and I'm not a big
fan of television commercials in a
facebook commercial world so that's kind
of how we think about it right like it's
it's the details like for me for example
I think like for example if you guys hey
guys we want to call your bluff Gary one
year you dictate the first thing I would
do is buy Super Bowl like that would be
the number one AD by I would do and then
the second thing would be Facebook
commercials and then the third thing is
Instagram influencers and that would
literally be my entire spend it's very
zoned in operationally to the company
very excited about Vayner solutions
being experienced trainer beta our live
event business our small business
offering our consulting offering the
only vulnerability when you have that
issue is how you decide to measure if
we're working or not which is which is
important and by the way the lifeline of
why we'd be able to hang out with you
longer the good news is this is such an
obnoxious arbitrage yeah it is using
networks you're going to get a feeling
you're gonna feel like you're going to
your your common sense driven not like I
work at you know so we have a with a
prayer but a really interesting mindset
maybe even sensing in the last couple of
episodes just sometimes you just get
deep like right now I'm there
in the dirt you guys have heard about my
clouds and dirt actually once you put a
little video thing there for a lot of
either new that I haven't seen it
sometimes you're in amok row sometimes
your micro you've been seeing the
meetings with the Boehner team there's
been a ton of stuff that you haven't
seen there's an all Boehner of media
time actually usually 90% of stuff that
you guys don't see day in day out is me
doing vaynermedia stuff it's really
interesting you know when I watch the
blog I'm like I talked about being 90%
this you know this company I'm like well
if you watch the blog it feels more like
60/40 cuz the speeches and the other
stuff but that's because so many so much
of my day today that also like so much
of my day can't be seen because you're
hiring you're firing your your hug my
clients at scale all stuff that
obviously I can't share your
strategizing I actually obviously put on
my best friend used to the world and so
not up not stopping you from that right
you'll see highlights of the pure while
meeting a couple things that I wanted to
talk about with the team and and where I
think we can help and then mate and then
we've got a okay you got to make some
decisions it's just because you're
worried about the short term and I'm
empathetic to that and like and like the
only thing I am is energy for the long
term right everybody here out of their
spirit out of being great out of their
P&L like the biggest problem I have in
this company with Ryan and Jeff cycling
in the room is like I'm empathetic
especially when I bring in a good CFO
who I want to for him to do his job but
the only thing we're doing here is I
want pure out to be number one and like
the end like Micah if you told me right
now out of your mouth our traffic would
go down 25 percent if we focused on this
I would approve it before we finish your
sentence I mean it you have to
understand there's a fundamental reason
I bought this company there's a
fundamental reason I have the career
that I have if you're going to live to
be in 2020 you might as well play to be
in 2020 we're good enough this is what's
so amazing about you guys this is the
other reason I bought you witness forget
about what I bring to the table you guys
are so good at getting to 2020 because
that's what you guys have done
you built this from scratch as a team
and have always over batted when you can
over sell your reality
but then build to the new reality that
how you get big right so like that's why
we're doing this because it's the
singular most important thing it's
really cool right I think gum I think
it's really interesting and important
for everybody to realize like the
motivational quotes on Instagram once
you throw a lunch up right here right
now motivational quotes on Instagram the
highlights the fancy people that I
interview on the askgaryvee show
once you cut in did you realize that was
a unicorn the unicorn I didn't expect
any tournament is to get all of eight
happiness is a byproduct not an actual
destination you have a camera like don't
overthink the quality like I want you to
do the work I like to sound like the
police in the mill here um it's all fine
and dandy but the the oxygen the engine
the gasoline that allows me to do that
is operating this enormous large agency
and they're very competitive landscape
at the highest levels in the world and I
love that and I love that action I love
that responsibility and I often talk
about the you know I genuinely believe
being in entrepreneurs being a
firefighter you know being in the 911
business it was probably a big
transition breeding site I like the
level of stress of being my assistant
versus even being aging the number two
guys it's just a quantum leap right I
was just thinking about today like you
see it's all disappearing easing eating
sharing eating [ __ ] at scale and so you
know even a quantum leap for all of you
you know trying to make this valuable
today suddenly begin an awesome
for all your number two's out there just
having empathy for your CEO for her day
in and day out where it's way crazier
you think that jump from two to one is
just everything it's really kind of
similar to being a child and being a
parent like you're in the family being
meaning all of this child versus being
the actual parent for all you oldest if
you're a number two action another get
very good piece of ice if you're number
two in a company and you happen to also
be the oldest child in your family and
you also happen to be of the age now
where you have children and you're the
head of your family or one of the top
two you and your family that's the
difference that's how want them I would
be oldest and the quantum leap of the
sense of responsibility that's the fear
of your child breathing and all that
stuff you know the quantum leap I
thought I was the oldest and I was like
11 years old and they DJ my dad worked a
lot I was banned but taking the dad
position it's a whole different game and
I think that's the difference winning
number to number one literally literally
when you're the CEO every single thing
is your sponsibility
oh they're a good one you recognize that
so I've been very in it it's you know
it's fun because when I go very micro it
leads to a lot of macro thoughts being
in the dirt is what helps me strategize
in the clouds it gives me the context
I'm learning I'm in it deeply in it and
so I'm in the zone right now and and
it's great because that a clouds level
the world has changed this is a primary
device of our society but if you were
hanging on to landing page optimization
on desktop to flyers to direct mail to
the television ads to pre-rolls on
YouTube like if you're hanging on to
banner ads programmatic buying if you're
hanging on to the things that got you
here you're about to be in a fertile
rude awakening the whole collapse of the
retail store market that I'm sure you've
been reading about if you're a business
person all these retail stores closing
that's just a preview of what's gonna
happen to every industry the Internet
has one in the middleman and it is uh
unemotionally an assassin and so the
companies that have built on top of that
and her leaders Amazon Apple Facebook
Google Netflix they're just getting
benefits of the [ __ ] macro gangster
which is the internet tomorrow's the
first time kids I recruited and closed
later Sports if you get trapped in the
NFL that's cool
you call Kathleen I'm gonna wear this
for like a month and people to be like
do you know where he picked that up and
underestimated at your own peril
I'm not underestimate I'm riding that
big [ __ ] waves all the way to second
Super Bowls big day tomorrow and if
they'll Draft should be plan episode
I'll see you later
leave